these driverless robo taxis in seoul's
sangam dong district aren't a publicity
stunt they're part of the city's 125
million dollar scheme for self-driving
cars
from tuesday they'll ferry passengers
between the digital media city rail
station and nearby apartment and office
buildings charging passengers about
three dollars a trip
by the end of december they'll be joined
by several more driverless cars as well
as a bus
to ease safety concerns the mayor
stepped in as the first official
passenger
at the beginning i felt a bit awkward
and a little bit nervous but soon the
car pulled over and started and changed
lanes and made a left turn and a right
turn very smoothly as i experienced this
i believed it would be a good start to
the commercial service
it's a small step but a large leap
considering the difficulty of the
research involved
the technology behind driverless cars is
being sought after by many major
technological companies
us-based tesla the market leader in
electric cars is still several years
away from completely removing drivers
from the equation
its full self-driving system is still
being tested and requires operators to
keep their hands on the wheel at all
times
earlier in november one of its cars
crashed in california after a
malfunction
but in so the outlook is more optimistic
[Music]
cars are no longer simply about moving
around autonomous vehicles have shifted
the paradigm leading to disruptive
innovation autonomous vehicles prevent
careless driving by humans minimizing
social costs
early next year the city says it will
add 10 driverless taxis to the gangnam
district as part of the pilot project's
second phase
and if everything goes off without a
hitch
the city government wants to grow its
self-driving fleet to more than 50
vehicles in the next five years
alexander lurch
al jazeera